[موسيقى] أجنبية
كنت مهتمًا جدًا بالسحر لفترة
طويلة جدًا ، لكنها كانت هواية في
معظم حياتي كنت
أعمل فيها منذ 16 عامًا في مجال
الضيافة وبعض أفضل الفنادق من فئة الخمس نجوم
في المنطقة  لكن السحر
كان دائمًا نوعًا ما في مؤخرة
ذهني وعندما كان في عام 2020 ،
كان لدى الجميع الكثير من وقت الفراغ في أيديهم
لحسن الحظ ، كان لدي الكثير من الوقت
لأقضيه مع السحر وأطور نوعًا من
تطويره بشكل جيد
أكثر من ذلك بقليل ، كان هذا هو الوقت الذي
ظهرت فيه الفكرة جيدًا لوجود العديد من
السحرة هنا ، حيث نتسكع دائمًا ونناقش
الحيل السحرية الجديدة التي
تشاركها المعرفة وتعرفها تشارك الأفكار وهناك
الكثير من السحرة الذين يتعين عليهم الطلب  من
الولايات المتحدة أو من أوروبا أو تعلم أنه
لم يكن هناك شيء ما هنا ، فقد
كان هذا هو الوقت الذي بدأت فيه الفكرة نوعًا ما ،
وهنا بدأنا في
تطويرها كمتجر كامل ومتجر سحري
وأردنا إنشاء نوع من
سفارة صغيرة هي مركز صغير
للسحرة هنا في دبي
من حيث الترفيه ، إنها مكان
بشكل أساسي للمحترفين للحصول على الكتب
والحصول على الحيل والدعائم الجديدة وأشياء من هذا القبيل
لذلك نحن نفعل معظم السحر الذي
نقوم به هنا هو المزيد للتوضيح  المنتجات أو
التأثيرات أو الحيل أو الكتب ولكن في
نفس الوقت لأنه مقهى
وأردنا أن يكون في متناول أي شخص
مهتم بالجو
الجيد والقهوة الجيدة أو فن السحر ، لذلك من
الواضح أن أي شخص يأتي
إلى المهتمين  سيكون السحر سعيدًا
لعرض بعض الحيل التي تؤدي
لهم وأنت تعلم تأكد من أن
الجميع يقضي وقتًا ممتعًا ،
شكرًا لك